The following content is
provided under a Creative
Commons license.
Your support will help
MIT OpenCourseWare
continue to offer high quality
educational resources for free.
To make a donation or
view additional materials
from hundreds of MIT courses,
visit MIT OpenCourseWare
at ocw.mit.edu.
PROFESSOR: So
welcome to this week.
We're going to talk
about trees mainly.
We're going to talk about
some very special ones,
spanning trees.
But before we do
this, you will go
through a whole
bunch of definitions
and look at examples to
explain how it works.
So let's talk about
walks and paths.
So you've already seen
a bit of graph theory.
We've talked about graph
colorings and so on.
But now we're going to talk
about special types of graphs,
and special structures
within such graphs.
Well, let's start with
the first definition.
How do we define a walk?
Well, a walk is
something very simple.
You walk from one vertex
in the graph over an edge
to a next vertex, to a
next vertex, and so on.
So how do we define this?
A walk is a sequence of vertices
that are connected by edges.
So for example, we
may have something
that looks like a first vertex.
That we call the start.
And an edge that goes
to a second vertex.
We continue like
this until the end,
say, at vk, which we
call the end of the walk.
And if you look at
this, we say this
is a walk from v0
all the way to vk.
It has exactly k edges.
And we say that the length
is actually equal to k.
So this is a very basic notion.
And what we are
really interested in
is actually paths.
And paths are special
types of walks
in which all those
vertices are actually
different from one another.
But let's first give
an example of a graph
that you will study throughout
the whole lecture, especially
when we come to spanning trees.
So let's have a look
at the following graph.
So let this be a graph.
And for example, we
can have a walk that
goes from this particular edge.
Say we call this v0.
It goes over this
edge over here.
Suppose I want to end over here.
Well, I can go many ways
in this particular one.
I can go for this edge.
I may go over here.
I may go all the way
to this part over here.
I may return if I want to.
And I finally, I take this
edge for example back to--
over this edge, I will
end in the last vertex vk.
So what we notice
here is that we
have a walk that actually gets
to this particular vertex,
and then returns to this vertex.
So for a few other edges, and
then goes all the way to vk.
So if you talk about
the path, then we really
want all the difference
vertices not to occur twice.
So let's define this
so the destination is
that a path is actually a walk.
Is a walk where all
edges, where all vertices,
vi's, are different.
In this particular
case-- well for example,
if you strip off
this part over here,
you will get a path from v0
to here, to here, to here.
And all these vertices
on the path on this walk
are different.
And therefore it is a path.
This also shows us something.
It is possible to construct
from a walk a path.
As you can see, we started
off with this particular walk.
And we just deleted,
essentially,
a part where we sort of came
back to the same vertex again.
And when we delete all
those kinds of parts,
you will end up with a path.
So can we formalize this
a little bit better?
Then we get the next lemma.
I call this lemma one.
And let's see whether
we can prove this.
So we want to show that if
there exists a walk from, say,
a vertex u to-- well, maybe
I should not use arrows.
That's confusing--
from u to v. Then there
also exists a path from u to v.
So how can we prove this?
Do you have any ideas?
So what kind of proof
techniques can we use here?
And maybe one of the
principles that we have seen?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
but I have an idea
about how you could show this.
It's basically if you
visit one vertex-- let's
you go 1, 2, 3, 4, 5, 3, 6.
You can walk from 1 to 6.
Then we just take out the
4, you just go 1, 2, 3, 6.
PROFESSOR: Right.
So what did we do there?
We essentially had a walk.
And then we cut out
a smaller parts here
that recurs in a sense.
And we have shortened the path,
we have shortened the walk
to a smaller path.
So what we've used here
is we can sort of take out
parts of the walk just
like we did over here
until the walk gets shorter,
and shorter, and shorter.
So maybe one of the things
that we may consider
is a walk of shortest length.
And we know that
this is possible.
Oops, sorry about that.
So let's prove this.
So for example, suppose there
exists such a walk from u
to v. Then we know by
the ordering principle
that there exists a
walk of minimum length.
So that's what we're
going to use here.
And then we're going
to essentially go
in the same direction as
what you were talking about
because we're going to show
that it's not possible to delete
anything more.
Because otherwise,
if you could do that,
the walk would get shorter.
And that's not possible, because
by the well ordering principle,
we simply consider that there
exists a walk of minimal length
that we are interested in.
We will show that this
particular walk is actually
going to be a path.
So let's see how we can do this.
So let's do walk be equal
to-- well, it starts in v0.
It's equal to u.
There's an edge to, say, v1.
It goes all the way up to vk,
which is the last vertex, v.
So what are we going to prove?
We're going to prove that
this is actually a path.
And since this is a
walk of minimal length,
well suppose it is not a path.
So we are going to
use contradiction.
Well if it's not a path, then
by our definitions over here,
there must be two
vertices that are actually
the same, just like in here.
So we go from v0 to, say, this
particular vertex, or this one.
And then we come
back to this one,
and then all the way to vk.
So if it is not a
path, then two of those
must be equal to one another.
And then we are going
to use this trick.
We're going to
take out this part.
We get the shorter walk.
But that contradicts that
our walk is minimal length.
So that's sort of the proof
technique that we're doing.
OK.
Let's do this.
So first, let's
consider a few cases.
If k equals 0, then
that's pretty obvious.
We have only a single vertex u
that is connected by a 0 length
path to itself.
So this is fine.
For k equals 1, we have
just a single edge.
And then we're done too.
That's a path as well.
So let's consider the case
where k is at least two.
Well, suppose it's a walk.
It's not a path.
So we are going to
assume the opposite.
If it's not a path,
then we concluded
that two of those vi's must
be equal to one another.
So there exits an i unequal to
j such that vertex vi equals vj.
Ah, but now we have
a walk that goes
from v0 all the way to, say,
vi, which is equal to vj.
And then we go all the way
up to vk which is equal to v.
So essentially, we have
created a shorter walk.
We have taken out this
little triangle over here.
Now this is a shorter walk.
And this contradicts our
assumption of minimality.
So that means that our
assumption over here
is not true.
So the walk is actually a path.
So this concludes the proof.
So even though this
lemma is pretty
straightforward in
the sense that we all
feel that if you have a walk,
then you can create a path,
if you really want to write it
down with all the principles
that we have been
taught, you can see
a few things appearing here.
So we first started with
the well ordering principle.
And also we used the method
of contradiction in our proof.
So let's set talk about
the next definition.
So we talked about
walks and paths.
Let's talk about connectivity.
We actually defined
two vertices, u and v
to be connected if
there is a path that
connects u to v. So
u and v are connected
if there is a path from u to v.
And now we can talk about the
graphs that are connected.
That's a very important concept.
A graph is connected if every
pair of vertices is connected.
So when every pair of vertices
in the graph are connected.
So an example is the particular
graph on the blackboard.
You can see here that
there's always a path
to be found from this vertex,
to this one, or to that one,
to this. to that,
to this, or that.
You can do this for
any two vertices.
So this is a connected graph.
A graph that is not
connected looks something
like this for example.
You may have a single
edge plus, say,
another triangle,
maybe with another edge
or something like that.
So they are disconnected
from this vertex.
I do not have a
graph that connects
to this vertex over here.
So this is about connectivity.
And now we can start talking
about cycles and closed walks.
Together, these concepts
will help us to define trees.
And then we can start
talking about this very
special concept, spanning trees.
So let's see how that works.
So cycles and closed walks.
We first define a closed walk.
And once we have done this, we
are able to get into cycles.
So what's a closed walk?
Well, it's actually a walk for
which the start and the end
vertex are the same.
So it starts and ends at
exactly the same vertex.
So this is all pretty
straightforward.
So we have v0 connected to,
say, v1, all the way up to vk.
And vk itself is equal to v0.
So you have a walk
that goes all the way
from v0 all the way back to vk.
For example, in this graph, you
could have walked all the way
back to v0.
You would have a closed walk.
So what's a cycle?
A cycle is a little
bit more special
in which all these
vertices over here
are actually different
from one another.
So if k is at least
three-- so the walk
is not just a simple edge,
or just a single vertex.
And if all v0, v1, all the way
up to vk minus 1 are different,
then we are saying
that we have a cycle.
Then it is called a cycle.
So these two concepts,
connectivity and cycles,
will help us to define trees.
So what are trees?
A simple example
is something that
looks like this, for example.
The idea is that a
tree is both connected.
And it has no cycles.
So in this case, we can see
that every vertex it's connected
to every other vertex.
But there is no cycle like
a triangle or something
that is connected all around.
So let's define this properly.
A definition is that a
connected and acyclic graph
is called a tree.
And within trees, we also
have something very special
that we call leaves.
And leaves are exactly those
nodes that have degree one.
So for example, this
node has degree one.
It has only this
edge connected to it.
So this is called a leaf.
This one also is a leaf
because it has just one edge
connected to it.
But this lead over
here has three edges.
So it has degree three.
This one has degree four.
This is the leaf again.
This one is a leaf,
this one, and this one.
So this is very
important concept.
We often use leaves
in our proofs.
And we will get to one.
So a lead is a node with
degree one in a tree.
OK great.
So now let's have
a look at trees.
Suppose I'm looking at
a subgraph of a tree.
What can we say
about a subgraph?
What kind of structure
does this have?
So suppose for example I want to
take some connected subgraphs.
So that's what I'm
actually interested in.
So for example, I
take this-- suppose
I take this connected subgraph.
Then what does it look like?
Do we see some
structure in this?
It's-- no?
AUDIENCE: It's a tree.
PROFESSOR: Yeah, it's a three.
So are we able to
prove this also?
So this lemma you
actually lose later on.
So any connected subgraph
of the tree is a tree.
And to prove-- well, how
can we start out a proof?
Any suggestions?
So let's have a look here.
So how may I think about this?
Well, I may take a
connected subgraph,
and I want to show--
of a tree- and I
want show that it is a tree.
A general method could
be, for example, to--
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
You know, one
of the things, one
of the conditions
is it has to be acyclical.
So since you're not adding
nodes and you're not
starting within cycles, you
can't create a new cycle.
PROFESSOR: Yeah.
I think you're saying
something like,
if I have a connected
subgraph, which
is like a smaller
part of the tree--
now suppose that
would not be a tree.
Say it would have a cycle.
Then that cycle would also be
present in the tree itself.
And that's not really possible
because a tree has no cycles.
So that's sort of indeed
how the proof goes.
So we essentially
use contradiction.
So let's suppose that this
connected subgraph is actually
not a tree.
So suppose it's a
connected subgraph.
It's not a tree.
Well then, in that case,
it must have a cycle,
because a tree is something
that is both connected
and has a cycle and is acyclic.
We have a connected subgraph,
which is not a tree.
So it must have a cycle.
So it has a cycle.
But now since it is a
subgraph of the bigger graph,
we know that the cycle must
also be in the whole graph.
So the whole graph has
this particular cycle.
Wait a minute.
The whole graph is the tree.
And a tree's acyclic.
So we get a contradiction.
So that means that our original
assumption that it's not a tree
is wrong.
So it is a tree.
So this is, again, such a
general kind of proof method
that we repeatedly use here.
So this lemma, which
we will call two,
we will use in the
next proof where
we're going to talk about the
relationship between vertices
and edges within trees.
It's a very beautiful
relationship.
The lemma states if you have
a tree that has n vertices,
then it must have
n minus 1 edges.
So this is a very tight
relationship here.
So a tree with n vertices
has n minus 1 edges.
So let's see.
How can we prove this one?
Any suggestions?
So what did we use at the
beginning of the course here?
So we have n vertices.
And we want to show that
it has n minus 1 edges.
We can use induction, right?
So let's use induction.
on n.
So how do we proceed
if you do this?
Well, we always start out
with an induction hypothesis.
So the statement here
would be something
like, well, there are n minus
1 edges in any n vertex tree.
And if you start with
induction, you always
start with the base case, right?
So we have the base case.
So how does this work?
So for example, we
want to consider P1.
So there are zero edges
in any one vertex tree.
Well, that's true, right?
If I have just one
vertex, there's no edge.
So this is definitely correct.
So that's easy.
So let's prove the other part,
which is the inductive step.
And the inductive step is--
So to do the inductive step, we
are going to always assume Pn.
And then we want
to prove Pn plus 1.
So let's do this.
So we have the inductive step.
And we always start
out the same way.
So we suppose P of n.
And now we want to
prove Pn plus 1.
So how do we do this?
Well, take a tree that has
n plus 1 vertices vertices.
And we want to show
that it has n edges.
So take any such tree.
So let T be a tree that
has n plus 1 vertices.
So how can we use the
induction hypothesis here?
So do you have any
ideas over here?
So I have a tree with
n plus 1 vertices.
And if I want to be able
to use this induction
at this induction
hypothesis, then I
can only apply it on trees
that have n vertices.
So somehow I have to
delete one vertex.
Right?
So what kind of vertex
can I delete in such a way
that we still have a tree?
And I need that because
this induction step can only
be applied to trees.
So what type of vertex can I
remove from a tree and it still
stays a tree?
So for example, if you look
at this example up here,
what kind of vertex
can I remove here?
AUDIENCE: A leaf.
PROFESSOR: Yeah, except.
I can remove a leaf--
for example, this one.
And why is that?
Because if there's only one
edge connected to the rest
of the tree-- so if I delete
it, I will actually keep a tree.
So that's how the
proof will continue.
So we take out one vertex.
So let v be a leaf of the tree.
And let's remove this
particular vertex.
So what do we get?
Well, we again have
a connected subgraph.
So this creates a
connected subgraph.
And we also know
that this is a tree.
So how can we conclude that?
Well, we had another
lemma somewhere
that's behind this blackboard.
It says that if you
have connected subgraph,
then we still have a tree.
So this is great.
So this is also a tree.
So now we can apply Pn
because we have n vertices,
because we deleted one.
So by Pn, we can conclude
that this particular subgraph
has n minus 1 edges.
You simply apply our
statement over here.
But we want to say something
about the original tree.
So how do we do this?
Well, we have to somehow
reconstruct this tree.
Well, we have deleted v. So
we have to reattach v again.
So let's do this.
So we reattach v.
And if I do this,
well, let's look at
this example over here.
I reattach the leaf.
I will add one more edge.
So if I reattach
this particular leaf,
I will get back the
original T over here.
And how many edges does it have?
Well, it has these
n minus 1 edges
plus the one edge that is
needed to reattach the leaf.
So that's all together
exactly n edges.
So now we have shown that for
every n plus 1 vertex tree,
every such tree has n edges.
So now we're done, because
this shows P n plus 1.
So this is how the
lemma is proved.
And in the homework,
you actually use this.
So let's now talk about very
special trees, spanning trees.
I think this is a
very exciting topic.
So let's look at this
particular graph over here.
Let's define spanning trees.
So what's a spanning tree?
A spanning tree is a subgraph of
a graph that somehow spans all
the vertices within this graph.
So it's a tree that touches
every single vertex.
So for example, we may have--
Maybe this is not
such a bright color.
Maybe this one.
So for example, we may have
a tree that looks like this.
So in this particular
graph, we can
create a subgraph with
the thickened green edges
over here, which is a
tree, and also covers
all the different vertices
of the original graph.
This is actually pretty
amazing that you can do this,
you can actually create
such a kind of tree.
And what you want to
prove, first of all,
is that for every
connected graph,
we can construct
such a spanning tree.
So let's first define this.
And then we will
prove this theorem.
And then after this, we're going
to talk about weighted graphs.
That will lead to minimum
weight spanning trees.
And then it gets
really interesting
because you want to figure
out how we can actually
construct those for any graph.
So let's define a spanning tree.
A spanning tree--
And we appreciate this as
SD-- of a connected graph
is actually a subgraph
that is a tree.
So that's the first condition.
And it also covers all
the other vertices.
So it has the same
vertices as the graph.
And over here, we
have this example.
So now what you want to show
is the following theorem
that any connected
graph actually
has such a spanning tree.
So the theorem is
every connected graph
has a spanning tree.
And let's think about
a proof together.
So for example, we may
start with the idea
to use a contradiction.
Suppose there exists
a connected graph that
has no spanning tree.
So how would we go ahead?
So how can we prove that we
have a contradiction here?
So the proof that we're
going to propose here
is by contradiction.
That means that we're going
to assume the opposite.
So assume that we have
a connected graph,
a connected graph G.
That has no spanning tree.
So how can we use this?
How could this be strange?
Or what can we do here?
So one of the nice things
about trees over here is--
so that maybe gives us some
insight is that if we have
a tree-- well, it seems like
such a kind of spanning tree is
like--
It's a solution to a
subgraph that is connected
with a minimum number of edges.
Like if I have any other type
of subgraph-- for example,
if it has cycles, I can always
remove an edge of course.
So we know a subgraph of G that
touches all the different edges
and has a cycle
can get shortened
by eliminating one
edge of a cycle that's
within such as a subgraph.
So maybe we have an idea here.
And maybe we can use this.
So maybe we can say, let's
set consider a graph T. So
let T be a connected subgraph
of G, but with a property
that it has a minimum
number of edges.
So let this be a
connected subgraph of G.
And we assume that it has the
same vertices of G of course.
In addition, it has the smallest
number of edges possible.
So what do we know?
Well, let's look at
our assumption here.
We said that a connected
graph, G-- that's
what we consider
here-- for which
there is no spanning tree.
So what do we know?
We know that this
particular T over here
can definitely not be a
spanning tree, because that's
what we assume here.
Can we use this?
So let's think about this.
So if it is not a spanning
tree, then what must it have?
So we already know that T
is a connected subgraph of G
with the same vertices of
G. So the only difference
between a spanning tree and T
is that the spanning tree is
a tree, and T is not a tree.
So therefor, T
must have a cycle.
So we use our
assumption over here.
We know that T is
not a spanning tree.
And now we can conclude
that it must have a cycle.
So now we can start
thinking about this cycle.
And let's feel--
What can we do here?
So we constructed T
as the subgraph that
has the minimum number
of edges possible.
So now if you have a
cycle, the whole idea
is that we're going to delete
one of the edges of the cycle.
And if you do that, we will
be able to construct a smaller
subgraph T, essentially, with
a smaller number of edges.
And that contradicts this
particular statement over here.
So that's sort of
how we go ahead.
So if it has a cycle,
let's write it out.
For example, here we
have a cycle like this.
Well, let's prove that if
we remove one of the cycle,
that we still have a
connected subgraph.
So the whole graph T
is much bigger, right?
It has lots of
connections and so on.
Suppose we will remove this
particular edge over here.
So we remove this one.
Do we still have a
connected subgraph of G
that covers all
the vertices of G?
Well, of course it cover
all the vertices of G
because we only removed
an edge over here.
So that's fine.
All these parts are still
connected to the rest.
If you can show that it is
connected, then well we just--
well, we removed one edge.
So we actually created
this smaller graph.
And then we get contradiction.
And then we're done
with our proof.
So let's see whether we
can prove that if we remove
this particular edge
over here, that we still
have a connected subgraph.
So how can we do this?
Well, let's take-- so the
first case would be if a vertex
x is connected to y.
So I want to take any
pair x, y of vertices.
And suppose that the path
that connects x and y
does not contain this particular
edge e that I remove here.
So suppose this
does not contain e.
So I look at the graph
T. I Know T is connected.
So I take a pair of
vertices x and y.
I know there is a path
between x and y in T.
If this path does not
contain the edge e,
then I know that the same path
still exists in the same graph
where I've removed
this particular edge.
So that's great, right?
I have shown that
x and y are still
connected in the new graph
where I've removed this e.
So now let's look
at another case.
For example, x is over here.
And it is connected all
the way through here
over this particular edge all
the way to, say, y over here.
So this is case number two.
Well, are x ad y
still connected?
Yes they are, right?
Because I have removed
e from a cycle.
So I can still go into the
other direction of the cycle
and connect back towards y.
So what we see here is that
x can go all the way to here.
But it can still go
over the cycle back
to here, and then to y.
So we are still connected.
So this shows that
in both of the cases,
for any pair of vertices,
even after removal of e,
the graph T minus this
edge e is still connected.
So let's write this out.
So all vertices in G
are still connected
after removing e from T.
So now we are done.
So what was that again?
We now constructed
a smaller graph--
smaller in the sense that it has
one less edge-- that is still
connected, and with
the same vertices as G.
But I assumed that T
was already the smallest
such graph, such subgraph.
So we have a contradiction.
So what does this mean?
This means that our original
assumption that we have over
here cannot be true because
we started off with this
assumption.
Because of this, we could
start to construct this.
And then you could derive
this whole argumentation.
And in the end, we
get a contradiction.
So our original
assumption is wrong.
So actually, this
is not possible.
There does not exist a connected
graph G that has no ST.
So the theorem is true.
So this is an important theorem.
So now we can start talking
about weighted minimum spanning
trees.
So let's use this picture over
here and assign some weights
to this graph.
So for example, we have 1,
2, 2, 3, 3, 3, a 1 over here,
another 1, 1, 4, and 7.
And let's construct
a spanning tree.
So let me give an
example over here.
Actually, this is an example
that we have right her
in the thick lines in green.
So what is the weight
of the spanning tree
that we have here?
So we simply add the
weights of all the edges.
So we have 7, 3.
That makes 10.
11, 14, another
2, 16, 17, 18, 19.
So the weight of this
particular spanning tree is 19.
So now the problem
is-- and that's
the rest of the
lecture-- how can you
construct a minimum
weight spanning
tree, one that has the
minimum weight possible?
So we see another example.
So could I swap
some edges around
or something like that such
that I can get a lesser weight?
So for example, over here,
I have-- for example,
this node over here is connected
by an edge that has weight 3.
But I could also
have connected it
to this particular one over
here, which is only weight 1.
If I do this, I actually improve
the spanning tree construction.
So I will get something
that looks like--
Let's see-- that
looks like this.
And now we replaced 3 by 1.
So it gets 17.
So can we do anything
less than this?
That's maybe-- it's
still a tree, right?
Because there's no cycle.
Here we have this, this,
this, this part over here.
If you want to have
connected subgraph,
I always need the 7 in here.
Well, it seems like you
cannot really replace anything
by something cheaper.
Like any edge in here seems
to be pretty necessary.
Of course, what I could
do is I could create
other minimum spanning trees.
So actually it turns out that
17 is the minimum weight.
For example, I could,
instead of this edge,
I could use this edge.
That's another solution.
Or instead of this edge,
I could use this edge.
So how do we construct such a
minimum weight spanning tree?
Can we somehow find an
algorithm that creates this?
And that's the big
problem of today.
So let me write out
one spanning tree
that I will use for
the rest of this class.
And maybe I will use a
little bit different color.
Let's use red over here.
I hope this is visible.
So we have red, this
one, and this one,
and this one, and this
one, and this one.
That's going to
be-- this is going
to be the spanning tree
that I'm going to look at.
This is also weight 17.
So let's first define what a
minimum weight spanning tree
is, just to be very precise.
And then let's
have an algorithm.
Maybe you have already ideas
of how this could be done.
It turns out actually
that if you just
start with a greedy
approach, you just
start to add sort of through
the edges of minimum weight,
that you can still add
without creating any cycles.
You will get an
algorithm that is
going to do the trick for you.
So that's kind of surprising.
So let's talk about
the definition.
So the minimum spanning tree
of an edge weighted graph
is defined as--
It's defined as the
spanning tree of G such
that it has the smallest
possible sum of edge weights.
Well the algorithm
that I'm thinking about
here is very straightforward.
Actually I'll use
this blackboard
because this algorithm
will be the focus
of the rest of the lecture.
So what's the algorithm?
We actually grow a
subgraph step by step.
So one edge at a time
such that at each step
we want to add the
minimum weight edge that
keeps the subgraph acyclic.
So this is our algorithm.
Let's have a look how this
works in this particular graph
over here.
So suppose I would
start off with-- well,
if I start with this algorithm.
I take, say, any
minimum weight edge.
Say I take this particular one.
So this could be my
first edge that I choose.
Then I may want to choose
another minimum weight
edge such that I do
not create a cycle.
Well, which one could I choose?
I could choose this one.
I could also choose this one.
With this one, I could
choose this part.
choose that part.
I could also choose this one.
So let's choose
this one actually.
This would be our second
step and our second edge
that we select in our algorithm.
There are two disjoint edges.
So there's definitely no graph.
Well, maybe now
our third step, I
can choose one of these edges,
which also has just weight
1, which is minimum weight.
So this could be my
third possibility.
Then what's the
fourth possibility?
Well, I have to choose
one of those actually.
I cannot choose
this weight 1 edge?
Why not?
Because that would
create a cycle.
So I'm not allowed to
choose this one anymore.
So I choose one of these two.
So for example, I choose
this one over here.
This is the fourth edge that
I add to the whole picture.
So note that in the meantime.
I have two disconnected
components.
One other here, which is this
arc, and another arc over here.
So which edge do I attach
now in the algorithm?
Well, I can still add
this minimum weight edge
over here of weight two, because
it does not create any cycle.
So this would be
the fifth wonder
that I add to the whole picture.
Well, now I can choose
either one of those.
So for example, this
would be my sixth step.
And then finally, I can
choose none of these
because those would
create cycles.
But I can choose this one.
So this is going to be
the seventh one that I
add to the whole graph
that I construct here
and grow in this algorithm.
It turns out that this algorithm
actually creates for you
a minimum spanning tree.
And the proof is
much more complex
than what you have seen before.
So that's what we're
going to do right now.
So when we think
about this algorithm,
then somehow I want to guarantee
that at every single step,
I will be able to grow into
a minimum spanning tree.
And that's the basic
intuition that we have.
And that's the lemma that
we want to prove first.
So formalizing, we
get the following.
We want to prove the
following statement.
So the lemma that will help us
is let S be the set of edges
that I have been selecting
up to now in the algorithm.
So let S consist, for
example, of the first m edges.
What we want to show
is that we can still
extend this set of edges
into a minimum spanning tree.
We can still grow
within the algorithm
into a minimum spanning tree.
That is what you want to show.
So we want to show that their
exists a minimum spanning tree
T that has the vertex
set V and an edge set E.
So this is the minimum
spanning tree for the graph G
such that S is actually
a subset of the edges
in this minimum spanning tree.
So this is a nice
mathematical formulation
that really precisely
states that we can still
keep on growing into a
minimum spanning tree.
So how would this lemma help
us in proving the theorem
that we want to show?
Actually, where is the theorem?
I did not write down
the theorem so far.
I can put this over here.
So the theorem
that's want to show
is that for any connected
weighted graph G,
the algorithm creates a
minimum spanning tree.
The algorithm produces
a minimum spanning tree.
So how can we prove his theorem?
Suppose we know that
this lemma is true,
which we will prove later.
Then how do we know
that this theorem holds?
Actually, I'm wiping out this
particular theorem over here.
We will use this in a moment.
So we know that every connected
graph has a spanning tree.
We already know that.
But now we want to
show that we can even
construct a minimum spanning
tree for a weighted graph.
So how are we going ahead?
The proof of the
theorem is as follows.
I will suppose that
the number of edges--
the number of vertices--
is actually equal to n.
And if we want to show that we
get to a minimum spanning tree,
we want to first of all
show that the algorithm
is able to choose at least
n minus 1 edges, right?
Because a tree has
n minus 1 edges.
We have shown this before.
The algorithm should
not get stuck.
So let's first prove that.
So suppose I have chosen
less than n minus 1 edges.
So suppose we have less
than n minus 1 edges picked.
Well then what do we know?
Well, there exists as
edge in E minus S--
well, let me first
write it out--
that can be added
without creating a cycle.
So why is this?
Well, I know that
E is the edge set
of my minimum spanning tree.
I know that S is a part of--
is a subset of all the edges.
I know that a minimum
spanning tree is a tree.
It's a tree on n vertices.
We know that's a tree on n
vertices has n minus 1 edges.
I know that less than n minus 1
edges have been chosen so far.
So that means that S has
less than n minus 1 edges.
E has successfully
n minus 1 edges.
So there's at least one
edge that is contained,
that it is an element
in E, but not in S.
And for that
particular edge-- well,
since it's part of
this tree, together
with S, which is also part of
all the edges within the tree--
well, we know that that
edge, for that reason,
will not create a cycle.
Because otherwise, the
original would have a cycle.
So we know that the
algorithm can always
select an edge such that's
no cycle is created.
And that means that we can
keep on going in the algorithm
until at least n minus
1 edges are selected.
So what happens if we
have n minus 1 edges?
So once n minus 1
edges have been chosen,
well, then S has
exactly n minus 1 edges.
E has exactly n minus 1
edges, because it's a tree.
They are subsets of one another.
So they must be
equal to one another.
So essentially what
we have here is
that S exactly defines
the minimum spanning tree
that we are looking for.
So the algorithm
at the very end,
when it has chosen
n minus 1 edges,
produces a minimum
spanning tree.
So we know that S defines
the edges of a minimum weight
spanning tree.
So if this lemma
really holds true,
then this theorem can be shown.
So now let's have a
look at this lemma.
And we're going to use
that picture over there
to see how we can prove this.
So this is a little bit tricky.
And the way to go about this
is actually to use induction.
So let's check see whether
we can do this together.
So the proof of the
lemma is as follows.
We want to use induction.
On what do you think we
are going to induct here?
Well, we want to prove
this particular lemma,
and we have this
particular variable m.
So that seems to be a
good methods to continue.
So we'll use induction on m.
Let's state the
induction hypothesis.
Well, it's exactly the
same as in the lemma.
So we say for all
G and for all sets
S that consists of the
first m selected edges,
there exists a minimum
spanning tree of G such
that S is a subset of E.
So this is how
induction hypothesis.
And as always, we start
with the base case.
And the base case is
going to be pretty
straightforward in
this particular case.
We have to do a little
bit of work for it.
So let's see how that works.
So the base case is m equals 0.
So let's reread this statement
where m is equal to 0.
Well, if we have zero selected
edges, then S is the empty set.
So I have to prove
that for all G,
there exists a minimum
spanning tree such
that the empty set is a subset
of E. Well, the empty set is
always a subset of E, right?
So that's no problem.
So what I need to proof
is that for all G,
there exists a minimum
spanning tree of G.
And this is where our
previous theorem comes in,
because we showed
that for all graphs G,
there exists a spanning tree.
And if there exists
a spanning tree,
there exists a minimum
weight spanning tree.
So that's the base case.
So m equals 0 implies that
S is equal to the empty set.
So that means that
S is definitely
a subset for any set of edges of
a minimum weight spanning tree.
And now we're going to use our
theorem to show that there also
exists a minimum spanning tree.
So this in itself is not
yet sufficient, right?
You see that.
I know that if S
is the empty set,
then I know that
this always holds.
But the statement is
a little bit bigger.
For all G, I still
need to prove there
exists a minimum spanning tree.
And that's what our
previous theorem told us.
So we'll now write
that part out.
So we have to base case.
Let's see.
I think I will go and
prove this over here.
So let's look at the--
That's the inductive step.
And then hopefully we can play
a little bit with this picture
up here to get some insight.
So how do we do this?
Well, with an inductive
step, we start as usual.
We assume that P of m holds.
Now how do we go ahead?
So I want to prove Pm plus
1, which is stated over here.
So I want to consider
the set S that
consists of the first n
plus 1 selected edges.
So well, essentially
what I'm interested in
is what happens in
the n plus 1 step.
So let E denote the edge that
I added in the m plus 1 step.
And let S be the first
m selected edges.
And we know that we can
apply p of m for S, right?
Because we assume this
is our inductive step.
So we can apply
something for S. We
would like to show Pm plus 1.
So we would like
to show something
for the union of those two.
So let me repeat that.
Let S denote the first
m selected edges.
So by our induction hypothesis,
we can-- well, let's apply it.
We know that there
exists a minimum spanning
tree such that S is a
subset of the edges.
So let's just pick one
such minimum spanning tree.
So let T star be such a
minimum spanning tree.
It has edges E star.
And we know that S is
actually a subset of E star.
Let's look at the
very first case.
So what are the kind of cases
that we are interested in?
So let's think again.
What do we need to prove?
We need to prove Pn plus 1.
So we need to prove something
about the union of S and E.
We want to show that there is
a minimum spanning tree such
that the edge set of this
minimum spanning tree
contains both S and also E.
So what kind of cases
can we handle here?
Well, what will be a
really good first case?
The first case could be
that E is actually already
part of E star.
Well, if that's true, then
of course, S together with E
is also a subset of E star.
And that means that we are
done, in this particular case.
And why is this?
Because this is an example of
a minimum spanning tree that
contains both S and E.
So it contains the n
plus 1 first selected edges.
And so this is Pn plus 1.
Now the next case is
the difficult part.
OK, let's wipe
out-- actually, we
do not really need the proof
of the theorem anymore.
So let's take this
off the blackboard.
So the way to do this
is to sort of see
how we can use the tree, T
star, and somehow transform it
into another tree for
this particular case
where we assume that
E is not in E star.
So let's have a look
at that graph up there.
Let me rewrite it a little bit.
And let's look at what
happens in the algorithm
after two steps.
So I will redraw the graph.
So we have, say, these edges.
This one-- let me see.
I want to use some different
colors to make this as clear
as possible.
We have this one.
And we also have
this one actually.
Sorry.
All right, so let's define
the different edges.
The straight ones
from the set S.
So after two steps over there,
we have selected this edge
first, and then this
edge was the second edge
that we selected
in our algorithm.
So these two together
form the set S.
So what is T star?
T star could be, for
example, the spanning tree
that contains both these
edges plus the dotted ones.
So let's have a look here.
This is indeed a tree, right?
And if we look into
this picture over here,
you can see that the weight
of this particular tree is 17.
It's also a minimum
weight spanning tree.
What is G?
G is the complete graph and
contains not only these two
types of edges, but also these
sort of more orange colored
ones.
So this is so the
situation that we are in.
Now in our algorithm,
we want to choose
this particular third edge.
So this is going to be our
e, this particular edge.
And as you can see, e
is not part of T star.
It's not one of those
two kinds of edges.
It's actually one
of the orange edges.
So what can we do here?
Well, the idea is that we
want to recreate like a you
tree in which we somehow
exchange e-- exchange one
of the edges in T
star with e, and still
sort of maintaining the
minimum spanning tree property.
So how can you prove this?
The way to do this
is to figure out
what the algorithm
teaches us about e,
and also what the tree
property tells us.
So let's combine
all our knowledge.
So first of all, we
know that the algorithm,
from its definition,
implies that as together
with e, actually has no cycle.
That's how we select
the n plus 1 edge.
There's no-- all
selected edged together
should not contain a cycle.
That's the definition
of the algorithm.
We know that T star is a tree.
And this implies that if
you look at the graph that
has the edges, has the
vertices V together
with E star with edge e, then
this must contain a cycle.
Now this property I will
not prove right now,
but it is pretty
straightforward.
It's a one line proof
actually in the book.
So you can look it up.
So it simply states that
if you have a tree, if you
add another edge, an edge that
is not contained in E star,
then we will create a cycle.
So now we can combine these
two statements together
and conclude that, well,
if S with e has no cycle,
but E star with e has a cycle,
and S is contained in E star,
well there's only
one possibility.
And that is that this cycle
must have an edge, e prime, that
is in E star minus S.
Because if it would
not have such an edge,
then all the edges of the cycle
must be located in S-- in S
together with E. But S
together with E has no cycle.
So that's not possible.
So this cycle must
have and edge e
prime that is outside
S, but still in E star.
So we can find one over here.
e prime can be this
particular edge.
So e prime is in E star.
But it is not already
selected in S.
So now we are going
to do a trick.
The idea is to
swap e and e prime.
So that's the main idea.
So let's first write down what
we know about the weight of e
prime and e.
So since the algorithm,
well, could have selected e
or e prime-- it did
select e, right?
But it could have
also selected e prime,
because e prime does not
create a cycle with S.
That's what we have seen here.
So this really implies
therefore that the weight of e
is at most the
weight of e prime.
So why is this?
Because the algorithm always
chooses the minimum weight.
And it can choose between e
or e prime, but it chose e.
So the weight of e must be less
than the weight of e prime.
So that's what we know also.
So now let's swap
e and e prime in T.
And then we're almost
done with this proof,
because that will be the tree
of which we will prove that it
is a minimum spanning tree.
So the key idea is to swap e and
e prime in T. How do we do it?
Well, let T double
star be equal to V
with the edge set
E double star where
E double star is really equal
to, well, the original set E
star.
But we take out of this e prime.
So this one is taken out of
the minimum spanning tree.
And we add e in here.
Now we want to prove
that this particular T
double star is a minimum
spanning tree that
fits our lemma.
So what do we know?
We know that T double
star is acyclic.
And why is this?
Well, we actually removed e
prime from the only cycle-- so
look up here also-- the
only cycle in E star
together with e.
So it's acyclic.
T double star is also connected.
And why is that?
Well, since e prime is
removed-- but it was on a cycle.
So it remains connected.
And finally, we also know
that T double star actually
contains all the vertices in
G. So all these three together
with prove that T double
star is a spanning tree of G,
because it's acyclic, connected,
contains all the vertices.
Is it a minimum
weight spanning tree?
Now we are really almost done,
because-- let me write it out
here.
We know that the
weight of T double star
is at most the weight of T star.
Why is this?
Well, we showed just
now that the weight of e
is at most the
weight of e prime.
So we have exchanged
e and e prime.
So that means that the
weight of T double star
is at most that of
the weight of T star.
We also know that T star
is a minimum spanning tree.
So if you combine
these two together,
then we know that the weight of
T double star cannot get less
than the minimum
weight possibility.
So it also has a minimum weight.
So T double star is a
minimum spanning tree.
So now we're done
because in this case,
we have constructed
a T double star such
that S together with E is
a subset of E double star.
And that means that we have
shown that our induction
step is true.
We have shown that
Pn plus 1 holds.
So now we finally have figured
out that the lemma is true.
And now we showed already how
to use the lemma in our proof
for this particular theorem.
So this is the end
of this lecture.
And tomorrow, you will actually
go again over this proof
because it's rather complex.
And then hopefully you
really get into all
the different proof techniques.
OK.
Thank you.